I seek refuge in God from Satan, the accursed.
In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful.
Praise be to God, who revealed the Book to His servant and
made it straight, to warn of a
severe punishment and to give good tidings to
the believers
who do righteous deeds that they will have a good reward,
abiding
therein forever. And to warn those who say, “God has taken a
son.” They have no knowledge of it.
Or is there
behind them a
word that comes out of their mouths? They speak nothing
but a lie. Perhaps
you would destroy yourself with grief over their footsteps
if they do not believe in this message. Indeed, We have
made that which is on the earth adornment for it that We may test them
[as to] which of them is best. And We have made a barren desert.
Or do you think that the companions of the cave and the inscription were among
Our signs a wonder? When the young men took refuge in the cave,
they said, “Our Lord is
mercy and prepare for us
from our affair right guidance.” So We made them dwell
in the cave for a number of years.
Then We awakened them to know
which of the two groups was more precise in calculating the time they had remained. We relate to you their story in truth. They were youths who believed in their Lord, and We increased them in guidance. And
We strengthened their hearts when they stood up and said, “Our
Lord is the Lord of the heavens and the earth. We will never
call upon anyone but God.”  We have
said, "If they have no god but God, why do they not bring forth a clear proof for them?" And who is more
unjust than one who invents a lie about God? And
when you have withdrawn from them and that which they worship other than God, then take refuge in the cave. Your Lord will spread out for you His mercy and prepare for you from your affair a facility. And you see the sun when it rises, passing by their cave on the
right, and when it sets, passing by them on the left, while they are
in a spacious opening thereof. That is
from the signs of God. He whom
God guides is the rightly guided, and he whom He leaves astray - you will never find for him. And you think them awake, while they are asleep. And We turned them
to the right and to the left, while their dog stretched out his forelegs at the entrance.
If you had looked at them, you would have turned away. And thus they will
turn
among them. One
of them said, "
How long have you stayed?" They said, "We have stayed a day or part of a day." They
said, "Your Lord knows best how long you stayed. So send one of you with
this silver coin of yours
to the city and let him look to which is the purest
food and bring you
provision from it."
If he finds out about
you,
they will return you to their religion, and then you will never succeed. And
thus is the
promise of God.  The truth is that the Hour is coming, there is
no doubt about it. When
they disputed
among themselves about their affair, they said, “Construct a building over them. Their
Lord knows best about them.”
Those who prevailed in their affair said, “
We will surely take a
mosque over them.”
[Music]
They will say, “Three, the fourth of them being their dog.” And they will say, “
Five.” And they will say, “Five, the sixth of them being their dog,” guessing at the unseen. And they will say, “
Seven, and the eighth of them being their dog.”
Say, “My Lord knows best
their number.
No one knows
of a few.” So do
not argue about them except with
God, and do
not ask any of them
for a ruling concerning them, and do not say [Music], “That is what God wills.” This is the heaven by which He wills. And hear: They have no protector besides Him, nor does He associate anyone in His rule. And what has
been revealed to you is only from the Book of your Lord. There is no changing His words, and you will not
find a refuge besides Him. And keep
yourself patient with those who call upon His
countenance and do not
desire the adornment of the worldly life. And do not obey one whose
heart We have made heedless of Our remembrance and who has followed his desire and whose affair has become excessive.
[Music] And
say, “The truth is from your Lord, so whoever wills - let him believe.”
[Music] Its canopy will encompass them, and if they cry for help,
how
wretched is the drink and evil is the resting place. Indeed, those who believe are righteous.
[Music]
[Music] They will be
adorned therein with bracelets of gold
and wear green garments of
[Music]
racing,
agreeing
in this matter. How great is the reward and how good a resting place!
[Music] To one of them were two gardens of grapevines, and We surrounded them with palm trees and placed between them some crops and caused a
river to gush forth between them. And he had fruit. So he said to
his companion while conversing with him, “I am greater than you in wealth and mightier in followers.” And
he entered his
garden while he was unjust to himself. He said, “
This is
forever
[Music]
to my Lord. I will surely find a better place of return than it.” His companion
said to him while conversing with him, “Have you
disbelieved in He who created you from
dust and then [
Music]
from a sperm-drop
[Music]?
But
God is my Lord, and I do not associate with my Lord anyone.
And why, when you entered your garden, did you not say, ‘What God wills [will come to pass]; there is
no power except in
God’? Do you not
see me as having less
good than your garden?” And He sends upon it a
calamity from the sky, and
it becomes a barren wasteland,
or its water becomes [
unable to obtain], and his fruit is encompassed [by ruin], so he began to turn
his hands about in despair, [and] it was destroyed, and it was
fallen upon its
trellises, and he said, “Oh, I wish I had not associated with my Lord…”  No one, and he had no
group to support him
besides God. And there was no
influence
there. The authority belongs to God, the Truth. He is the best in reward and the best in outcome. The
life of this world is like water which is
called from the sky, and the vegetation of the earth mingles with it, and it becomes dry stubble scattered by the
winds. And
God is over
all things competent.
Wealth and children are the adornment of this worldly life, but the enduring good deeds are
better with your Lord in reward and better in hope. We will
move the mountains and make the
earth bare, and We will gather them and not leave out any of them. You have certainly come to
Us just as We created you the first time. Rather, you claimed
[music]. So you will see the
criminals fearful of that within
it, and they will say, "Woe to
us!"
The Book of God. And there is
no great thing but that He has enumerated it, and they will find
what they did present. And your Lord does not wrong anyone. And all the
angels were commanded to prostrate to Adam, and they prostrated, except Iblis. He
was of the jinn and disobeyed the
command of his Lord. Then will you take him and his offspring as allies
besides Me? I did not make them witnesses to
the creation of the heavens and the earth, nor to the creation of the earth. I would not have taken the misleaders as helpers. And on the Day He will say, "
Call upon My partners whom you claimed  So
they called them, but they did not
respond to them. And We placed between them a course of action, and they
found no way out of it.
In this Qur'an for mankind are examples of every kind. And
man is ever contentious. And they do not believe
when guidance comes to them, nor do they seek forgiveness and seek
forgiveness from their Lord unless the precedent of the former peoples comes to them
or the punishment comes to them directly.
[Music] And the
messengers did not reach them except as bringers of good tidings and warners. And
those who disbelieve dispute with falsehood to refute thereby the truth. And they take My verses as their guide. And who is more unjust than one who is
reminded of the verses of his Lord but turns away from them and forgets what his hands have put forth? Indeed, We have placed coverings
over their hearts. And if you invite them to
guidance, they will never be guided. And your Lord is the Forgiving, the Merciful, for what they
have earned. For His Majesty is the appointed time of
God. And
those cities - We destroyed them. [
Music] The
third [appointment]: I will not cease until I reach the junction of the two seas or
continue for a long period. So when they reached the
junction between them, they forgot their fish, and it took its way
into the sea, making a tunnel. And when they had passed beyond it, he said to his servant, "Come here. We have met this." He
said, "Do you remember when we took refuge by the rock? Indeed, I
forgot the fish, and none
but Satan made me forget it."  He remembered him and took his way into
the sea, a wonder. He said, “That is what we were seeking.” So they retraced their steps and
found one of Our servants to whom We had granted
mercy.
[Music]
What
he said: “Do
you know anything of what you have been taught?” He said, “You will never be able to have
patience with me. And how can you have patience for what you have no knowledge of?” God willing. He
said, “If you follow me, do not ask me about anything until I explain it to you.” So they set out.
When they embarked on the ship, he made a hole in it. He said, “You made a hole in it?
Is this something?” He said, “Did I not tell you that
you will never be able to have
patience with me?” He said, “
Do not hold me accountable for what I forgot, and do not burden me with hardship in my affair.” So they set out.
When they met a boy, he killed him. He said, “Have you killed an innocent soul for no reason? You have certainly done a terrible thing.” He said, “Did I not tell
you that you will never be able to have patience with me? So do not
accompany me. You have reached the limit of my excuse.” When they
came to the people of a town, they asked its people for food.
He was able
to add to it a wall that he intended to demolish, so he repaired it. He
said, “If you wished, you could have taken payment for it.” He said, “This is the parting between
me and you. I will inform you…”
As for the ship, it belonged to poor people working at
sea, and I intended to damage it. And
behind them was a
ship seized by force.
As for the boy, his parents were believers, and we feared that he would overburden them with transgression and disbelief, so we
intended that their Lord should substitute for them one better than him, purer and nearer to
mercy.
As for the wall, it belonged to two orphan boys
in the city, and beneath it was a
treasure belonging to them, and their father was righteous. So your
Lord intended that they reach maturity and
extract their treasure, as a mercy from your Lord. And I did not
do that. That is the
interpretation of what you could not bear patiently. And
they ask you about Dhul-Qarnayn. Say, "I will recite to you a
mention. Indeed, We established
him in the land and gave him access to everything. So he followed a way
until, when he reached the setting of the sun, he found it
setting in a muddy spring.
[Music] It
takes on beauty among them.
He said,
[Music] to them, 'A
righteous man, so for him is the reward of good.' And We will tell
him of Our command, 'Conceal it.' Then he followed a way until, when the
rising of the sun  The sun was found rising on a people for whom We had not made any shelter from it.
Thus We had encompassed all that he had in knowledge.
Then he followed a way until, when he reached between the two mountains,
he found beyond them a
people who did
not understand a word. They said, “
This is the law of the two mountains. There is a barrier
between you and them. Bring me
pieces of iron.”
[Music] The
hadith is
new. Until, when he had leveled between the two mountains, he said, “
Blow
until you
know that I will
pour molten copper over it.” So they were unable to make a hole in it.
He said, “This is a mercy from my Lord.” But when
the promise of my Lord comes, He will level it, and the Oneness of my
Lord is true. And
We left some of them that Day surging against one another, and the Trumpet will be blown, and
We will gather them all together. And We will present
Hell that Day to the disbelievers
who were mentioned in
My remembrance, and they were unable to hear. So do those who disbelieve think that they can take My
servants as
allies? Indeed, We have prepared
Hell for the disbelievers as an abode. O you who are among
you in Luxor, indeed, those whose
efforts have been lost in this worldly life, while they think that they are doing well in work.
Those are the ones who
disbelieved in the signs of their Lord and in the meeting with Him, so
their deeds have become worthless, and We will not assign them a place on the Day of Resurrection.  And
We weighed
[music]
Those who do
good deeds will have the Gardens of
Paradise as their eternal abode,
never desiring any change therefrom.
If the sea were ink for the words of my Lord, the sea would be exhausted
before the words of my Lord were exhausted, even if We brought the like of it as a
supplement.
Now,
I am with
you. Your
God is but one God. So whoever
hopes for the
good of
God,
their interests